>> President Trump: WE HAVE A
MASSIVE TRADE DEFICIT WITH
ALMOST EVERY COUNTRY.
WE WILL STRAIGHTEN THAT OUT.
WE ARE ACTUALLY WORKING ON
CUTTING TARIFFS, AND WE'VE MADE
A LOT OF PROGRESS.
IT COULD BE THAT NAFTA WILL BE A
DIFFERENT FORM, IT WILL BE WITH
CANADA, WITH MEXICO, ONE ON ONE
MUCH SIMPLER AGREEMENT AND MUCH
EASIER TO DO.
>> Bret: A TRAIT IS THE BIG
TALK IN THE G7 SUMMIT IN CANADA
AND THEY ARE MEETING WITH
CANADIAN PRIME MINISTER TO.
JUST A SHORT TIME AGO, THE
PRESIDENT MET WITH FRENCH
PRESIDENT MACRON WHO SPOKE ABOUT
THE TARIFFS THAT THE U.S. IS
IMPOSING SPECIFICALLY ON STEEL
AND ALUMINUM.
TRANSLATOR MACK THE FOUNDATION
WHICH HAS BEEN USED TO JUSTIFY
THESE MEASURES IN AN ATTEMPT TO
PRESENT THEM ACCORDING TO
COMMERCIAL LAW WAS AN ARGUMENT
OF NATIONAL SECURITY.
NOBODY WOULD THINK THAT THE
IMPORTS OF STEEL AND ALUMINUM
COMING FROM CANADA OR FRANCE OR
OTHER EUROPEAN COUNTRIES WAS OF
A THREATENING NATURE.
>> Bret: SO WHERE DO WE GO
FROM HERE ON THE G7, AND WHAT'S
COMING OUT OF IT?
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL.
BYRON YORK, CHARLES LENA, AND
TOM BEVAN, REAL CLEAR POLITICS
COFOUNDER AND PRESIDENT.
ALL RIGHT, THERE ARE OBVIOUSLY A
NUMBER OF LEADERS THAT HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THE TARIFF
SITUATION BUT THEY ARE TALKING
IT THROUGH, IT SEEMS.
>> THEY ARE.
I THINK THE FIRST THING TO NOTE
ABOUT THE SUMMIT IS THE
PRESIDENT SEEMS TOTALLY FOCUSED
ON NORTH KOREA.
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT HE
SEEMS TOTALLY FOCUSED ON, BUT
THE BIGGER THING IS, THE
PRESIDENT IS SIMPLY INCAPABLE OF
ENGAGING IN THE DIPLOMATIC
NICETIES THAT YOU HAVE TO DEAL
WITH, THAT YOU HAVE TO DO AT
THESE MEETINGS.
THEY NORMALLY GOVERN THESE
MEETINGS.
HE IS THE ANTI-DIPLOMAT.
LAST YEAR HE WAS PUSHING ON NATO
TO CONTRIBUTE MORE TO THEIR
DEFENSE, NOW HE'S PUSHING OTHER
COUNTRIES ON TRADE TO GET THE
UNITED STATES A BETTER DEAL.
HIS THEME IS ALWAYS, THAT OTHER
COUNTRIES ARE TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF THE BIG, RICH, UNITED STATES.
IN THE END, HE WILL GET A LITTLE
BIT OF WHAT HE'S ASKING FOR.
>> Bret: AT THE OTHER THING
IS, HE'S STIRRING THE POT BEFORE
LEAVING FOR THE SUMMIT.
HE SAID THIS ABOUT HAVING RUSSIA
BACK IN.
>> President Trump: I HAVE
BEEN RUSSIA'S FIRST       WORSTN
BEEN RUSSIA'S FIRST       WORSTG
BEEN RUSSIA'S FIRST       WORSTT
BEEN RUSSIA'S FIRST       WORSTA
BEEN RUSSIA'S FIRST       WORSTE
BEEN RUSSIA'S FIRST       WORST.
THAT BEING SAID, WHY ARE WE
HAVING A MEETING WITHOUT RUSSIA?
WHETHER YOU LIKE IT OR NOT, AND
IT MAY NOT BE POLITICALLY
CORRECT, BUT WE HAVE A WORLD TO
RUN.
WE SHOULD HAVE RUSSIA AT THE
NEGOTIATING TABLE.
>> Bret: CHUCK?
>> THERE IS SO MUCH TO COMMENT
ON IN THAT ONE LITTLE STATEMENT.
RUSSIA WAS CAST OUT OF WHAT WAS
THEN THE G8 AND PUNISHMENT FOR
AN EGREGIOUS VIOLATION OF
INTERNATIONAL LAW, THAT IS THE
SEIZURE OF CRIMEA IN 2014.
MOST RECENTLY, THEY VIOLATED
INTERNATIONAL LAW AGAIN BY
ATTEMPTING TO ASSASSINATE TO
PEOPLE WITHIN BRITAIN, AND IN
THE UNITED STATES ITSELF
PARTICIPATED IN COLLECTIVE
RETALIATION SANCTIONS BASED ON
THAT.
SO, FOR THE PRESIDENT TO SOUND
THIS NOTE OF URGENCY, THAT WE
HAVE TO GET RUSSIA BACK IN THE
ROOM SO WE CAN RUN THE WORLD
TOGETHER IS JUST AT ODDS WITH
ALL OF THAT RECENT HISTORY.
AND I'M SURE IT MUST HAVE BEEN
VERY PUZZLING AND DISMAYING TO
THESE TRADITIONAL WESTERN ALLIES
WHO ARE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT EXACTLY IT IS THAT HE IS
DRIVING AT.
AND IN SOME CASES THAT CAN BE
USEFUL.
THE PROBLEM IS, YOU HAVE TO HAVE
A BOTTOM LINE AT SOME POINT.
I THINK WHAT THESE OTHER
COUNTRIES FIND IT SO BAFFLING
AND ULTIMATELY FRUSTRATING IS,
IS HEADING UP A SITUATION IN
WHICH THE ONLY WAY THEY CAN GIVE
HIM WHAT HE WANTS AT THE END IS
TO BE HUMILIATED BY HIM.
IN OTHER WORDS, HE'S MAKING
THESE OPEN-ENDED DEMANDS IN SUCH
A TONE THAT THE ONLY WAY TO SAY
YES IS TO ACCEPT YOUR OWN
HUMILIATION, AND I'M NOT SURE
THAT WILL LEAD ANYWHERE.
>> Bret: TOM?
>> I THINK CHUCK AND BYRON ARE
BOTH RIGHT.
ONE THING PEOPLE LIKED ABOUT
TRUMP IS THAT HE IS A FIGHTER,
AND BELIEVE IT OR NOT, THERE IS
WIDESPREAD AGREEMENT ON THE FACT
THAT SOME OF THESE TRADE DEALS
ARE UNFAIR TO THE UNITED STATES.
EVEN BUSINESS LEADERS WILL TELL
YOU THAT, AND THE NEED TO BE
RECALIBRATED AND RENEGOTIATED.
THEY ALSO HAVE AN ISSUE WITH THE
STYLE IN WHICH TRUMP IS DOING
IT, AND SOME OF THE TACTICS THAT
HE'S USING.
SO THAT IS PART OF THE PROBLEM.
HE IS CERTAINLY NOW IN FULL
HONEY BADGER MODE AND HE'S
ATTACKING EVERYBODY.
WE WILL SEE WHERE THAT ENDS UP
BLEEDING.
I THINK HE WILL END UP GETTING
SOMETHING, AND BE ABLE TO
DECLARE SOME SORT OF VICTORY,
BUT I THINK HE HAS CERTAINLY PUT
THE REST OF THE WORLD ON NOTICE
THAT HE'S NOT MESSING AROUND
WHEN IT COMES TO RENEGOTIATING
THESE TRADE DEALS.
>> Bret: I LIKE THAT, FULL
HONEY BADGER MODE.
HE IS THE FIGURE THERE AS FAR AS
MAKING HEADLINES, BUT AS YOU
LOOK AT THE GDP OF THESE
COUNTRIES AND COMPARE THEM
COLLECTIVELY, THEY DON'T ADD UP
TO WHAT THE GDP OF THE
UNITED STATES IS.
SO THAT TELLS YOU A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT HOW THIS IS ALL GOING
DOWN, BYRON.
>> IT DOES, EVERYTHING IN THE
UNITED STATES HAS A GREATER
EMPHASIS THAN ANYTHING ELSE.
SO TRUMP HERE AGAIN WILL COME
AWAY WITH SOMETHING.
THE TALK HE DID TODAY ABOUT
RENEGOTIATING NAFTA SO IT WOULD
NOT BE PAYING A NORTH AMERICAN
AGREEMENT, IT WOULD BE A
ONE-ON-ONE AGREEMENT BETWEEN
UNITED STATES AND CANADA WERE
BETWEEN THE UNITED STATES AND
MEXICO SHOWS THAT HE'S ACTUALLY
THINKING ABOUT FUNDAMENTALLY
RESTRUCTURING SOME OF THESE
AGREEMENTS.
AND BECAUSE OF THOSE GDP FIGURES
THAT YOU JUST SHOWED A COME OF
THE OTHER COUNTRIES DON'T HAVE
ANY OTHER CHOICE BUT TO
NEGOTIATE WITH THEM.
>> Bret: AS OF THIS
NEGOTIATION IS ONGOING, BUT HE'S
GETTING READY FOR ANOTHER ONE.
WE WILL TALK ABOUT THAT IN THE
FRIDAY LIGHTNING ROUND, TALK.
BUT THERE ARE LOTS OF BIG
MOMENTS FOR THIS PRESIDENT AT
THIS TIME.
>> Chuck: YES, AND JUST TO
COME BACK TO WHAT BYRON SAID IT,
NO OTHER CHOICE.
IN OTHER WORDS, YES THE
UNITED STATES HAS TREMENDOUS
LEVERAGE.
WE ARE THE BIGGEST ECONOMY BY
FAR END OF THE END OF THE DAY
THEY HAD TO DEAL WITH US.
BUT WHAT IS SO CONCERNED ABOUT
THIS AND LOTS OF DIFFERENT, THAT
HAD NOT BEEN THE BASIS ON WHICH
WE HAVE DEALT WITH THESE
PARTICULAR COUNTRIES OVER TIME.
THAT, YOU HAVE NO CHOICE.
IT'S MUCH MORE A QUESTION OF
MUTUAL INTEREST AND MUTUAL
VALUES, AND THIS IS REALLY WHAT
I THINK THEY FIND SO BAFFLING